in den letzten monaten und jahren habe
ich mir etwas an gewöhnt dass seitdem
mein leben in vielerlei hinsicht
verändert und vor allem verbessert hat
nein ich bin nicht gläubig geworden und
ich habe auch nicht mit großen
angefangen was ich mache ist deutlich
einfacher und zwar tracking
ich dokumentiere mein leben in diesem
video will ich euch mal zeigen wie mein
system funktioniert wir das auch machen
könnt und ob das alles auch wirklich
wissenschaftlich fundiert ist oder ob
ich nur einen placeboeffekt spüren
[Musik]
dieses video wird unterstützt von nord
wpm nord wpm belegt bei unabhängigen
tests zum beispiel von chip oder von
computerbild immer wieder die vordersten
plätze
und deswegen haben uns auch entschieden
mit nord bpm zu kooperieren
die einrichtung auf dem handy am tablet
oder am pc ist kinderleicht und erlaubt
euch das internet so anzusteuern
als würdet ihr in 60 ländern überall auf
der welt sein
so kann man zum beispiel auch dass
netflix angebot aus anderen ländern
anschauen und zum beispiel dexter oder
twin peaks gucken bei der
geschwindigkeit muss man auch keine
abstriche machen es gibt unbegrenzt
bandbreite und zumindest bei mir zu
hause habe ich keinen unterschied mit
oder ohne nordlibyen festgestellt im
gegenteil nur vpn kann dein internet
sogar schneller machen
manchmal priorisieren internetanbieter
andere verbindungen
deswegen kann es vorkommen dass zum
beispiel spiele downloads abends und
besonders in der stadt mal etwas
langsamer sind und auch so etwas kannst
du mit einem vpn einfach umgehen und das
beste ist mit dem code um doktor watson
bekommt er sogar einen monat gratis wenn
ihr euch ein zwei jahres paket holt und
keine sorge
jpn speichert keine nutzerdaten und wenn
jetzt noch nicht überzeugt seid habt ihr
30 tage zeit das euch anders zu
überlegen und dann euer geld noch zurück
zu bekommen
wenn ich das interessiert dann geht
jetzt auch noch die passion doktor
watson oder nutzt beim checkout den
coach doktor watson um euch 100 gratis
zu sichern
und jetzt gehts weiter mit dem video ok
erstmal was track ich alles kurz gesagt
mein glück meinen körper und mein geld
und das alles mal durch digital über
apps auf meinem handy zum einen halte
ich jeden tag fest wie es mir eigentlich
geht jeden abend lasse ich den tag revue
passieren und tragen in einer app ein ob
der tag sehr gut gut mittelmäßig
schlecht oder richtig schlecht war
da unterschreibe ich dann oft noch kurz
was ich an dem tag eigentlich gemacht
habe und vielleicht auch warum dieser
tag besonders gut oder besonders
schlecht war und das mache ich schon
seit über zwei jahren es gibt mir ganz
guten überblick wo ich eigentlich gerade
stehen mit meinem gemütszustand dann
treffe ich meine finanzen wie viel geld
kommt eigentlich jeden monat rein und
wie viel geld gebe ich wofür auch wieder
aus immer wenn ich mit bargeld zahlen
das kenne ich entweder den kassenbon ein
oder trage das ganz kurz händisch in die
app ein und den rest kann sich die app
einfach was meinem bankkonto ziehen und
zu guter letzt dreckig seit anfang des
jahres was ich esse und wieviel
sportlich mache bzw
in letzter zeit auch sehr viel wie viel
spazieren gehe dann viel mehr kann man
eigentlich nicht durchmachen
außerdem trage ich jeden tag mein
gewicht und noch einige andere daten von
einer waage ein wie zum beispiel fett
und muskelanteil und ich weiß genau was
jetzt denkt weil ich vor einigen jahren
noch genau dasselbe gedacht habe warum
warum machst du dir den ganzen aufwand
das kostet doch mega ist die zeit und
nerven oder dazu zweierlei maß kostet
ein bisschen zeit aber ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so viel ich würde mal schätzen
dass ich jeden tag so ungefähr zehn
minuten in dieses tracking meiner
diversen bereiche stecke das meiste
essen kann ich zum beispiel per barcode
einscannen oder ich finde einfach
rezepte die schon vorbereitet von
anderen usern in der datenbank sind und
nerven kostet mich das auch nicht so
wirklich ist es wirklich eine gewohnheit
geworden wenn ich etwas kaufe dann ist
es ein automatismus dass ich das dann
noch ein trage
wenn ich abends im bett liegend ist es
für mich normal den tag zu bewerten ob
der gut lief oder nicht so gut
und daraus ergibt sich der viel
wichtigere zweite teil der antwort warum
mache ich das weil ich gemerkt habe dass
oft das tracking alleine schon eine
verbesserung des gemessenen wertes
bewirkt dadurch dass ich aufschreibe was
ich esse bin ich mir bewusst was ich
esse und esse automatisch gesünder
klar ich sehe auch manchmal welche
inhaltsstoffe irgendwo drin sind dann
denke ich mir so wow das ist ziemlich
viel vielleicht er sich doch besser was
anderes aber ich glaube dass ein anderer
faktor noch viel viel größer ist auch
wenn ich meine werte und zahlen nie
jemand anderem zeige ich selber sehe sie
ja ich werde quasi beobachtet von mir
selber dadurch dass mir bewusst wird wie
viel ich für etwas ausgeben wird geld
ausgeben so etwas über das ich nachdenke
und nichts mehr was ich einfach so mache
will ich wirklich so viel geld für etwas
ausgeben bringt mir das so viel freude
das ist ein bekannter effekt es wird der
wert optimiert an dem erfolg gemessen
wird schulen werden schon seit vielen
jahren dafür kritisiert dass die
schülerinnen und schüler nur noch auf
klausuren vorbereiten und nicht nur auf
das leben und unternehmen wissen ganz
genau welche details welche key
performance indicators sie drücken
müssen weil diese optimiert werden und
auch in der wissenschaft ist das ein
bekannter faktor diese studie hier hat
eine korrelation zwischen erfolgreichem
gewichtsverlust und helft tracking apps
gefunden und diese studie hier aus dem
jahr 2016 kommt sogar noch zu einem 4
weitreichenderen ergebnis
studienteilnehmerinnen und
studienteilnehmer haben
verhalten über drei monate hinweg
geändert nur weil sie an einer studie
teilgenommen haben und ich selber hab
das auch an mir gemerkt zb habe ich mir
eigentlich gar nicht vorgenommen
gesünder zu essen ich wollte abnehmen ja
aber dafür muss ich nur weniger kalorien
essen
trotzdem habe ich mich dabei erwischt
wie ich immer weniger süßigkeiten
gegessen und immer mehr gekocht habe
erwischt zwar als gut
ich habe neue rezepte ausprobiert ich
habe mich mehr über proteine und über
ballaststoffe informiert es geht beim
trekking übrigens nicht immer darum
super mega genau zu sagen zumindest mir
selber nicht und auch wenn ich ein
großer fan von statistiken und grafen
bin und da gerne lange drauf gucke würde
ich euch auch empfehlen auch mal fünfe
gerade sein zu lassen
man kann nicht immer jeden euro
eintragen und man hat auch nicht immer
eine küchenwaage dabei um das essen zu
wiegen schon kann ich im restaurant
manchmal reicht auch pi mal daumen denn
es geht sowieso viel mehr darum
langfristiges verhalten zu beobachten
die großen trends gebe ich über wochen
und monate weniger aus als vorher
perfekt nämlich langsam aber stetig ab
oder halte ich auch nur mein gewicht
ohne zuzunehmen sehr gut von einem auf
den anderen tag kann so was schon mal
schwanken aber das macht alles nichts
solange der trend stimmt an das ganze
etwas lockerer heranzugehen hilft vor
allem wenn es ums essen geht denn
tracking birgt auch gefahren das solltet
ihr unbedingt erwähnt werden
man kann durch tracking obsessives
verhalten entwickeln
jede kalorien hinterfragen die freude am
essen verlieren und so auf dauer sogar
verlernen auf seinen körper zu hören
man entwickelt im schlimmsten fall sogar
eine krankheit deswegen fangen manche
leute erst gar nicht mit kalorien zählen
an
aber solange er eine gesunde beziehung
zu essen habt gibt es keinen grund warum
wir nicht mit tracking anfangen könnte
oft hilft es auch nur einen überblick
ein gefühl zu bekommen
ich habe nicht vor dem rest meines
lebens jede einzelne kalorie und jeden
euro zu drücken
aber ich baue mir gerade gesunde
gewohnheiten auf die ins
unterbewusstsein übergehen und wenn ich
merke dass irgendwas dann doch mal
irgendwann wieder aus dem ruder gelaufen
ist zum beispiel wenn ich dann doch
wieder zugenommen habe oder am ende des
monats kein geld mehr zum sparen übrig
bleibt dann kann ich wieder mit tracking
anfangen und das problem in den griff zu
bekommen
übrigens ist das alles beim thema glück
etwas komplizierter
das ist natürlich nicht so mathematisch
getrieben wie die anderen beiden
bereiche kann nicht einfach mal
glücklichen momente von den glücklichen
abziehen und wenn er möchte etwas übrig
bleibt dann ist alles im grünen bereich
wie geht es eher darum zu erkennen was
mich glücklich macht und frühzeitig zu
erkennen wenn es mir über einen längeren
zeitraum nicht gut geht oder ich stress
habe auf diese art und weise habe ich
zum beispiel herausgefunden dass ist mir
richtig gut tut meine freunde zu sehen
stocker hätte wahrscheinlich niemals
gedacht ist wahrscheinlich bei allen so
aber ich habe tatsächlich eine
korrelation in der app zwischen dem wort
freunde und glücklicheren tagen
ich kann das nachweisen dass das so ist
andersherum könnte ich so auch erkennen
wenn wir bestimmte dinge den tag
versorgen und genau diese dann gezielt
aus meinem leben verbannen
man kann nicht nur glück ernährung und
geld strecken man kann alle strecken was
man optimieren oder im blick behalten
will
die bildschirmzeit am handy wie viel man
und was man lernt oder wie oft man
meditiert und man kann dinge unendlich
viel individualisieren man muss ja nicht
die komplette ernährung tracken
man kann auch nur eintragen wie viele
süßigkeiten man ist oder ob man genug
wasser getrunken hat weil alles andere
ja eigentlich im rahmen ist oder man
legt nur einen sparplan an
denn solange man 50 euro pro monat spart
ist ja eigentlich egal wofür ich den
rest ausgebe wichtig ist nur dass man es
zu einer gewohnheit macht ich drücke
euch die daumen schreibt mir mal in die
kommentare was ihr schrecken volt und
lasst euch nicht schrecken sondern
benutzt nord bpm links und in der video
beschreibung ansonsten wie man vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
patrick
[Musik]
tracking irgendwas davon wird auf jeden
fall auch pech